it seems to me that inventing the enemy
could also be called needing the enemy
needing and Eventing and
inventing is the English title isn't it
job because the Italian teacher costume
is building up how to construct
step-by-step the enemy we need an enemy
why why do we need enemies for
reinforcing our own identity
I tell you the story but with which I
opened the essay you are kindly quoting
I was in New York I was talking with the
taxi driver I always talk with the taxi
driver because they give you the the the
the temperature
General temperature and it was a
Pakistan and they were asking me you to
come from I said either where is Italy
in Europe what kind of language the
English no no we don't speak English
that's curious but uh
and a certain point he asked what is
your enemy I said what do you mean no
the enemy you have seen centuries and
centuries you are fighting against you
are killing him and they are killing you
your your Eternal enemies I said we we
do heaven and we don't have a fixed
enemy for
in the 19th century Force half a century
when Austria but then finished by the
way we we started the the last World War
with one enemy and we ended it with
another one so
we don't have enemies
and he looked at me as I was really
emasculated and our people was
well people without without any form of
virility and so on so forth well by the
way it's okay what the French call Liz
parides I reflecting afterwards I
realized you know we have an enemy
simply the other people have an enemy
outside the Border Lies We have an enemy
inside the Border Lines there for two
thousand years the Italian cities were
fighting each other and even now the
Italian opposition was unable to to win
Berlusconi because they were fighting
against each other
fell down by his personal virtue not
because of the virtue of the opposition
but that's another is another story
every uh
every Power had in order to keep its
people United to invent somebody which
was
other
Oak
friends it sounds better with the
capital a
other and different
even those likely different but
different and then
like
the praga cemetery even the image of the
enemy follows certain fixed features and
he has a pattern
can you vote no we don't have to confess
the secret no no can you vote please
address the audience as they cannot hear
when you look at the
okay when you my dear audience they they
made the idea of yes
you know basically
um I I have a feeling they don't like it
when we look at each other so um I kind
of like looking at you but um the people
at intelligence Square would prefer that
we refrain so okay we don't look it
don't look at me
okay so um this is a form of enemy I
can't look at you
well from no well I was saying that was
that from the beginning one of the first
uh
pattern of the figure of the enemy is in
the early years of Christianity the
Antichrist
it is curliest big nose
a strange feet that's a but
fundamentally it stinks and the same
pattern is used during the centuries to
to the to represent the Muslim enemy
theoretic enemy the Jewish enemy so
always the same pattern to make the
enemy
archetypically repugnant
such that in every case you have to
refuse it in the sense in which Darwin
demonstrated that the phase movements in
order to express
disgusts are all the same in every
civilization
certain movement of the of the mouth of
the nose and so on and so forth so in
every civilization there was a
construction of the figure of the of the
enemy that's all in this essay I put
down now certain
quotations of different kinds of enemies
everybody
from satra to to James Bond you have in
a fantastic passage you're a big reader
of Ian Fleming yes I always also wrote
an essay on on the novens of I mean not
on the movies on the on the novels of
living yes and Fleming is exceptional
because he has the Russian enemy the
German enemy then the Chinese doctor no
the Chinese enemies as a good collection
until the international one which is
Bluff and who is Bluff
but another another
feature of the enemy in Fleming it is
that it's always of Uncertain
nationality
never a pure English man so always a
matech
only the effect of some blood mixture
here in this essay you you you spell it
out very clearly you say trying to
understand other people means destroying
the stereotype type without denying or
ignoring the otherness in
Prague Cemetery
you have sorry if I turn my my hand
because to listen no no but it's true
thank you thank you for reminding me in
the practice
no it's not natural it's not
it doesn't sound natural then it doesn't
sound like deadly
so it
yeah in the Prague Cemetery you have
told us a story
with every character being
absolutely real in history except for
one
that character is haunting simonemi and
you have constructed in him I must say
probably what you wanted to construct
namely I mean construct a merely in
terms of invention
I mean it is your invention you have
invented the vilest
ugliest most horrendous most disgusting
most despicable human being thank you
you're very much
[Music]
[Applause]
why why give us the depiction of
somebody quite as ugly as he is simonini
is fundamentally a forgerer but also a
murderer and fundamentally a racist and
in the opening Pages he pronounces
horrible judgments not only against the
Jews but against the German the the
French the Italians the women
and he
and he uses such a horrible material
such horrible cliche
that in a way I was
preoccupied that some reader could
identify
him herself with him so to keep the
reader distant and probably also myself
distant I had to to make him
as repugnant as you
as you said
then
once taking this decision there was also
the sincere pleasure of the narrator to
invent the character like this to make
him the the most immoral person because
you know the story he has the right
patterns and he decides if you sell them
to to the Freemasons against the Jesuit
or to the Jesuits against the Freemason
or to certain point he discovers that
anti-Semitism is more rentable in that
historical moment and the
Concords the protocols of the Elders of
Zion and he is participated to The
Dreyfuss Affair and he makes many other
many other it was an invented character
because for narrative reasons the wiser
I would have written another
academic book on that story I I had to
attribute to the same person the Deeds
of many of many others so I had to
invent it but I insisting in saying that
it is the twist
do is one of the of the old novel
because in telling the story he had
continuously the impression of speaking
of somebody that was living around me
the world is full of simoninis
and so he was telling a story of the
19th century but
well I would like my reader to go around
with this novel like a bedecker visiting
the world and say oh look one simulini
you never count you can do that with a
certain probability of success
foreign